Every retail sales person in America
just secretly wants to get through life
without ever being accused of being a
pushy salesperson.
Um,
and so the man in the desert story,
um,
you know,
guys,
there's a,
there's a silly a story in the world,
I mean,
until I made it up because it's so
silly,
but the guy is,
this guy lives on an oasis in the desert
and he looks out one day and there's
a man that's been obviously stranded in
the desert for days,
uh,
kind of,
kind of approaching a serious,
uh,
you know,
approaching death or something.
He's like,
well,
and so what happens in retail,
in the retail industry is people rush up
to him and give him a glass of water.
And then they,
um,
he drinks the water and they pat
themselves on the back and the man of
the desert wanders off some more and
they're feeling great about themselves.
You know,
that one,
I got the guy a glass of water.
And so we,
there's so much more that you can do for
him.
You need to intuit his needs and you
know,
let's see.
He needs more than water.
He's been out there for days,
he needs food.
He,
he might need electrolytes,
not just a water.
So let's give him some gatorade or you
know,
he needs to call his family and let them
know that he's okay,
you know,
and,
and not to mention Aloe Vera and all of
that.
So you're really the man in the desert.
You're fulfilling his needs.
Intuiting is nice and filling them,
uh,
through conversation and through it's
hard work.
Uh,
but you know,
you're,
you're doing all of that.
Then you can feel good about yourself.
Man and desert puts the moral imperative
if you will,
on selling rather than not selling
somebody that really understands the
mountain desert.
A story will understand that I'm selling
and service for the same thing.
We're not training people to sell up,
sell this.
Just help them in the true sense of the
word.
Just help the customer and the true
sense of the word.
And um,
you can only help the customer and help
the company or you can hurt the customer
and hurt the company if you went out and
give them a glass of water,
then you're just kind of wimping out
because you're afraid of being seen as a
pushy salesperson.
You're hurting the customer and in
you're hurting the company.
So if there's a woman in the container
store,
closet section and she's got a tie rack
in one hand in a shoe rack and the other
hand,
I mean she obviously has a closet
somewhere that's driving her crazy and,
and you can conclude that fairly safely
and if you let her get out of there with
those two items,
she's still got to have a closet,
was driving her crazy,
but the ties and the shoes will be a
little bit better off,
which you can do is,
you know,
causing interaction with her to find it
and,
and take a complete closet approach to
really kind of redoing her whole closet.
And what that will usually lead up to is
a customer that's vastly happier because
she got a problem solved.
She got her car and she's dancing in the
closet because it's so perfect.
That's what we're trying to get.
We're trying to get what we call the
customer dance.
Then you have a really delighted
customer who's coming back quickly who's
so delighted with her closet that she's
showing,
um,
her sister in law and her next door
neighbor that closet and then they're
coming in because they want,
they want that feeling too,
and they're like emotionally thrilled
with this closet or pantry or toys
towards solution or whatever.
And that's how we build our business and
an old market or a new market.
And ultimately what people want is they
want to feel emotional about the brands,
about the prototype,
this stuff home.
And they live with it for a very long
time and they either cus you every time
they see it or they smile and they were
very,
very happy about it.
So we talk about that.
You can get people to be emotional even
about something as pedestrian as a
trashcan.
We probably have the world's,
I think we have the world's best
selection of trash cans and even a trash
can can make you smile if you have this
man in the desert interaction between
customer and salesperson.
She's got a lacquer trash cans so much
as it fits in that corner perfectly.
You love the way the pedal opens and
closes,
closes you're,
you're actually kind of proud of your
trash can.
You're,
you've considered showing it off to
house gifts that you have over it stuff
and proudly saying,
no,
that's my trash can.
When you think about,
you know,
my trashcan,
and that's man in the desert selling.
You're just trying to help her figure
out what she needs to feel that way.
And uh,
people want emotion.